[Music]
in less than a year spider-man into the
spider-verse 2 will be released in
theaters not much is really known so far
except that the so-called spider-verse
is likely to be even more odd well sony
posted two images on twitter a few days
ago many fans were rather disappointed
and pleasantly surprised you can see the
classic spider-man costume in front of
the big city setting though it is
unclear which spider-man is behind the
masquerade the director is joaquim dos
santos who has already worked on avatar
the last airbender or the legend of
korra whether spider-man into the
spider-verse 2 can match the 375 million
dollar box office takings of its
forerunner we will be able to find out
from october 7th 2022
walnut brothers epic dune film adaption
is definitely one of the surprise hits
of this cinematic year of course fans of
the book series and the first movie
version already knew about the great
potential however the final result must
have surprised even them after the film
has been running in u.s theaters for
over a week warner and legendary decided
to officially announce this sequel to
the desert spectacle director danny
volnev may now venture further into
frank herbert's novel series and delve
deeper into the complex story we won't
know exactly what happens next with paul
his mother and the fram for roughly two
years with dune part 2 set to be
released in theaters on october 20th
2023
tom holland's probably last mcu film
spider-man no way home will soon hit
theaters after peter parker's identity
is revealed and his request for help
from doctor strange backfires we can
expect an extraordinary multiverse
spectacle despite the fact that the
second trailer has still not been
released there have been a total of 5
new images in recent days on the twitter
channel of empire magazine you cannot
only see the latest cover in all its
glory but also pictures from the film on
them you can see spiderman captured by
the tentacles of dog well almost all of
the images are obviously very dark ugh
heavy and wet the appetite for more in
the issue released on october 28th
another two images appear one showing mj
and spider-man in action and the other
showing dog under a bridge in other
pictures we get a look at spider-man
without a mask and ones with a mask
fleeing from darkhawk the latter image
is reminiscent of the scene from the
trailer in which doc ock makes his first
appearance all in all this is nice stuff
to look at what fans including us one
most of all is of course a second
trailer it shouldn't take too long now
since spider-man no way home will be
released in cinemas on december 17 2021
it is impossible to imagine the star
wars universe without hating
christiansen in the 2000s the 40 year
old canadian played the role of anakin
skywalker aka darth vader in episode 2
and episode 3. at the beginning of his
star wars career christiansen was highly
controversial among fans many simply not
satisfied with him playing the role of
this super villain fortunately this
opinion has changed considerably and
christensen is now one of the more
popular star wars actors all the greater
was the joy when he announced a while
ago his return to the obi-wan kenobi
miniseries which is currently still in
production well now there's more news
because as the hollywood reporter
informs obi-wan kenobi will not remain
the only series in which christiansen
plays his most famous role we are
referring to the upcoming ahsoka series
which is set about five years after star
wars episode 6 return of the jedi and
thus also after the mandalorian season
2. clever fans should not be puzzled
after all darth vader actually died in
episode 6 after the final clash with
luke this raises the question as to how
anakin skywalker will appear in the
series one obvious guess that anakin
will appear as a force ghost similar to
his appearance at the end of episode 6.
another possibility is of course the
appearance and several flashbacks to the
time of the clone wars when the
relationship between anakin and ahsoka
strengthened such scenes are of course
already known from the animated series
the clone wars that doesn't mean however
that some scenes couldn't be reworked in
live action format we are definitely
excited and look forward to seeing
hayden christiansen in the ahsoka series
by disney plus which will probably not
be released until 2023 significantly
earlier will be the release of the book
of boba fett series instead which isn't
the mandalorian spin-off as well fans
can expect a streaming start on december
29th 2021
in the upcoming sonic p hedgehog 2 there
will not only be a return of the
antagonist dr robotnik but also several
completely new appearances of characters
from the sonic universe among them is
not only sonic's faithful companion
tales but also the initially hostile
knuckles who at first sights with dr
robotnik since august we know that idris
alba will dub the red echidna in an
interview with screenrant a few days ago
the 49 year old brit with a distinctive
voice talked about his role as knuckles
dubbing actor albert was unable to
reveal much yet due to contractual
commitments of course but there
definitely won't be as sexy sounding
knuckles the origin of this sexy
knuckles narrative is unclear but it is
more or less a funny in joke about the
rap the domineering and stubborn
character as opposed to a serious fetish
surrounding the fictional character sexy
sounding knuckles would be out of place
in a family friendly franchise like
sonic anyway many fans reacted to albus
statement on social media with faint
outrage others can hardly imagine
knuckles not being sexy in the movie
regardless this is an interesting
discussion that will certainly have
another few highlights before the film's
release on april 8th 2022
this year was a special one for u.s
actor brandon fraser the 52 year old
went viral and dominated the topics of
social media channels for weeks this
year the reason for this was neither a
major scandal nor premature demise
instead the net community decided to
simply express their gratitude and
celebrate the likable and humble people
behind many hollywood characters in the
1990s now many fans will be happy to
know that the mummy actor will soon be
seen in a new role the dog is of the dc
comic book adaption batgirl which is
currently in production fraser is two
stars with pyromaniac villain firefly
and give batgirl a hard time she in turn
will be embodied by leslie grace while
j.k simmons also gets to return to the
role of commissioner gordon after the
justice league snyder cut there's still
very little information about the story
but is mainly about the duality of
barbara gordon and her alter ego batgirl
which she first finds out about during
the series directors adele l arby and
bilal fallout will be in charge of
directing bringing the script by birds
of prey writer christina hodson to life
the batgirl series is currently still in
production but is expected to debut on
hbo max as early as next year
the barbie doll from the us company
mattel is probably one of the best known
toys in the world no wonder then that
various movie studios have tried their
luck at several adaptions in the past
for almost two years now a live-action
adaption with margot robbie has been
under consideration after many of those
responsible have previously abandoned
the project in addition to robbie
another big hollywood star could soon
announce his involvement and that is
none other than blade runner 2049 actor
ryan gosling if deadline is to be
believed warner brothers and their
favorite gosling are already in the
final stages of contract negotiations
for the role of kim many film fans are
naturally wondering what exactly the
plot of such a film adaption could
consist of after all barbie is first and
foremost a toy and not a movie franchise
the main character will certainly not
appear as a dumb blonde like barbie has
often been made out to be in the past
first of all such an image is not
contemporary and second reita gerwig a
woman who's not known for indulging in
role cliches will assume the director's
role either way warner brothers seems to
see great potential in the project as
evidenced not least by the signing of
top stars gosling and robbie whether the
story will live up to the great effort
remains to be seen yet a little
skepticism is certainly not unreasonable
filming on barbie is scheduled to start
next spring
this week we can especially recommend
the new trailer for the fantasy epic the
wheel of time besides this are you a die
hard harry potter fan do you want to be
up to date with the latest news about
the franchise then take a look at our
movie preview of fantastic beasts the
secrets of dumbledore on our channel you
won't regret it
[Music]